Winston Churchill once said I generated
what we're going to try to do probably
you didn't catch any of that neither did
we from his early childhood Winston
Churchill battled against a speech
impediment whilst he never succeeded in
overcoming it he did however succeed in
becoming popular online will AI
technology be able to improve the
quality of this recording let's find out
let's upload the original audio into the
audio quality improvement tool enhance
speech and now let's slow Churchill down
a little and compare the two audios I
generate that is what we are going to
try to do
Virginia rate Denny's Rodriguez you
dried renewal well what do you think can
you understand what he's talking about
now we think the audio has become
clearer but it's not been able to make
up for Churchill's original
pronunciation this is a task for the AI
of the future